es min online jefe del ejército de
mianmar el 27 de enero había dicho a
soldados del ejército que la
constitución debía abolir se si no se
cumplía un día antes uno de sus
portavoces se había negado a descartar
un golpe de estado desde las elecciones
de noviembre el partido de la
solidaridad y el desarrollo de la unión
creado por la junta militar que gobernó
entre 1962 y 2011 está denunciando
fraude en la victoria del partido liga
nacional para la democracia de la premio
nobel de la paz aún san suu si la
comisión electoral negó cualquier fraude
así como la comunidad internacional
desde eeuu hasta la unión europea el
partido liberal de shuichi consiguió el
83% de los escaños es decir 396 de los
476 de ambas cámaras del parlamento
aumentando el apoyo desde que el 2015
llegase al poder
succi que no puede ser presidenta por
tener familiares de otras nacionalidades
es la líder de su partido y el
presidente responde ante ella cabe
destacar que estuvo bajo arresto
domiciliario hasta 2010
pese a que su fama cayó por la limpieza
étnica de la minoría musulmana rohingya
sigue contando con respaldo de la
ciudadanía de mianmar sin embargo los
militares controlan un país que no ha
terminado de democratizarse y que vive
una guerra constante desde 1948 con
múltiples guerrillas en las periferias
el 25 por ciento de los escaños
parlamentarios pertenecen al cuerpo
militar además de ocupar tres
ministerios interior que controla los
servicios públicos defensa y fronteras
por lo que el ejército nunca se ha
sometido a un gobierno civil tampoco se
ha conseguido una verdadera
federalización de un país de mayoría
budista que cuenta con 135 etnias ni
tampoco se ha logrado una efectiva
separación de poderes